[Música]
hola como estan yo estoy parado acá hoy
para contarles que hace más de 15 años
que convivo casi todos los días de mi
vida con la mentira y la manipulación
pero para sacar un poco de dramatismo no
a esta afirmación que acabo de hacer
primero necesito contarles un poco de mi
vida
mi nombre es gervasio antonio soy hijo
de antonio humberto la riva y alias el
beto y rené margarita de y más conocida
como la marga
una 100 mil 975 una ciudad que todos
ustedes conocen esta y tuve la suerte de
cruzarme en esta vida con una persona a
la cual a mí mucho mi adorada tía elida
el área dionísia a la que por razones
obvias decidimos apoyar la que acá
esa fanática carnavalera fue creo la
primer persona que descubrió en mi estas
características que me hacían un poquito
diferente llámese especial
imagínense
es ha utilizado un término para
referirse a mí que yo en ese momento no
entendía mucho ella le encantaba decir a
mí me encanta ir al curso con machito
machito me decía a ella porque va chico
es detallista
sí sí una siendo la cabeza un n de seis
siete u ocho años
imaginen que puede interpretar por ese
término si con el paso del tiempo logre
decodificar que quizás esa fue la
palabra más dulce que ella encontró para
adjetivar
esa sensibilidad que crecía en mí
que en los 80 en un pueblo habilitaba la
burla y la cargada
por suerte casi todas las realidades
incómodas tienen válvulas de escape que
nos permiten resistir y en mi caso esa
válvulas fueron los colores
así que mientras mi papá insistía en
enviarme actividades como por ejemplo
karate natación de la lectura oa la
colonia el bichito de luz que yo
detestaba
porque según su propia palabra esperaba
que se me formara algo de cintura algo
que evidentemente podemos apreciar que
no surtió el efecto buscado
mi mamá un poco más corriente o por
preguntarme enferma que quería hacer vos
a lo que mi pregunta inmediata fue
dibujo y pintura
así fue como a los 7 años comencé a
asistir todos los sábados a la mañana al
taller de eduardo ayala y no existía
mejor plan para mí que despertarme los
sábados sabiendo que ese día para poder
mezclar mucho color
un plan que se convertía en ideal si a
la hora de la siesta a la tarde mientras
mi viejo dormía yo aprovechaba y me
robaba del almacén una caja de fibra
silva tengo en la cual pintaba
absolutamente todo todo todo lo que caía
en mis manos
además esa caja tenía un doble uso
porque durante el día servía para
guardar las fibras pero por la noche se
convertía en el baúl donde yo iba a
guardar como un tesoro todas las piedras
lentejuelas canutillos que se
desprendían de los trastes de los
carnavaleros a su paso por la esquina
del automóvil club donde religiosamente
mi adorada tía que acá nos llevaba todas
las tardes de carnaval a reservar sillas
para la familia
sabían ustedes que pantón es del
catalogo pantone eligió este año como
color 2019 a este color el coral el
living coral este es un dato que no es
menor dentro de mi historia y le voy a
explicar porque recién les dije los 80s
en esa época cuanto más vibrante el
color mejor
seguramente alguno podrá llegar a
imaginarse que mi primer acercamiento al
mundo del maquillaje fue a través de la
carta a los reyes magos suplicándoles
por favor que este año me trajeran no la
pelota sino la valijita juliana
maquilladora no no fue así
fuego en algo mucho más banal que en los
80 era furor a través del catálogo de
avon que una clienta del almacén solía
traerle todos los meses a mi mamá
deseando que le comprara algo en esa
situación se generaba con una especie de
juego tácito así en el cual mi vieja me
decía
elegimos color del área que te guste
para mí y esa era la llave que a mí me
habilita va automáticamente a sumergirme
en un mundo de colores donde siempre
pero siempre terminaba eligiendo el
mismo
este la vida al que seguramente nunca
iba a usar
es el labial que era tan estridente tan
brillante que seguramente iba a terminar
en el botiquín del baño entre la
'charisma' y el sweet con espn
es el labial el más vibrante que tenía
un nombre muy especial coral tropical
ese labial tuvo su debut sobre la boca
de mi mamá una tarde en que mi papá tuvo
la maravillosa idea de ir a presentarles
el auto que nos habíamos comprado a unos
parientes mi papá nunca se caracterizó
por tener muchas ganas de salir de casa
así que las pocas veces que decía 'vamos
mi vieja decía unicef a volar afronten
sen antes de que se arrepienta vieron
que entre ríos no nos vestimos no nos
preparamos nos afrontamos así que
estábamos todos corriendo afrontando nos
para llegar a tiempo terminamos en el
auto que faltaba mi mamá así que mi papá
detalle menor es cáncer ya no
no es muy fanático de la espera y además
tiene muy poco uso de las palabras pero
cuando abre la boca a preguntar
cuestión que estábamos esperando falta
de mamá papá optó por empezar a los
bocinazos en esta situación sale mi
madre de la casa cierra la llave cierra
la puerta con llave se da vuelta y
cuando se da vuelta la vemos así nos
encandila con su boca pintada de coral
tropical se sube al auto
blasfemando como buena leoninas y bien
cabrona empezó a decir que es una
vergüenza que nos salimos nunca con una
vez que salimos mira toque salir así
nomás y que estoy acá que yo y todo ante
la impávida mirada de mi padre que no le
sacaba los ojos de la boca hasta que en
un momento reaccionó se daba vuelta nos
mira y nos dicen saben que gurises lo
peor es que vamos a llegar tarde porque
a su madre se le ocurrió dibujarse en la
cara un culo de mono mandril
un poeta
un teórico del color
por años mi relación con el color coral
tuvo que ver con esta anécdota pero por
suerte el tiempo nos permite
resignificar esas situaciones así que
estando en la facultad entendí que el
color coral estaba más relacionado con
un color formado como un rosa intenso
que se le saca un poco de blanco y se le
agrega amarillo y lista la explicación y
ustedes se preguntarán por qué 7 tanto
con el coral porque hagan este punto
donde voy a relacionar el color coral
con mi concepto de la belleza según mi
visión tanto el color coral como la
belleza son difíciles de definir son
difíciles de clasificar todos vamos a
tener una mirada diferente sobre los
mismos
así como mi papá relacionaba el coral
con el culo de un mono
para mí es un rosa intenso con una parte
de amarillo seguramente para uno de
ustedes sea más rojo para otro más
naranja para otro más magenta para otros
más rosados con la belleza pasa
exactamente lo mismo todos vamos a tener
una visión diferente sobre la misma
el término maquillaje proviene de el
germánico antiguo de la palabra marcar
que no significa otra cosa más que
esculpir o amasar
de ahí lo tomo la lengua francesa y lo
convirtió en la palabra maquillaje pero
para referirse explícitamente a la
máscara que se dibujaban los actores
antes de salir a escena en el teatro
comenzó siendo un término aplicado en el
teatro pero que su uso luego fue
extendido a salas hacia toda la sociedad
en italiano la palabra que se utiliza
para definir al maquillaje es truco si
es truco así como truco truco de magia
mentira ilusión y trucados es el término
que se utiliza para referirse al que lo
realiza el maquillador en este punto es
donde comienzan a unirse los conceptos
de los que habló al principio
mentira y manipulación porque así como
un mago utiliza la ilusión para hacernos
creer algo el maquillador esculpe sobre
un rostro dibuja una nueva forma sobre
una estructura para ser modificada
en la búsqueda de un ideal o para
modificar algo que al matizado no le
gusta
yo nunca pensé que iba a ser la
maquilladora de hecho nunca acredita un
poco mucho en horóscopos pero en segundo
año de la facultad un profesor de dibujo
fanático de la astrología me pidió que
leyera mis datos para hacer mi carta
astral
a ver cuando se es estudiante
universitario y del interior todo lo que
está gratuito bienvenido
así que no lo dudes que dispensamos una
cita al día tal hora antes de esa
cuestión y unos días después me lo
encuentro y me llevo en la grata
sorpresa que según mi carta astral y
según sus textuales palabras había
nacido con el don de manipular la
belleza
para que entendiera un poco más me dijo
a ver entendamos los así si uno
estuviera estudiando medicina podría ser
perfectamente un excelente cirujano
plástico estudiando lo que estás
haciendo esas artes podría ser un
fabuloso maquillador y yo lo miré como
a ver a ver dividamos las cosas soy de
los que una gota de sangre y convulsiona
así que la cirugía no iba a ser lo mío
pero aquí que no va a haber o sea nos
hemos estado formándome para dedicarme a
un oficio tan pero tan gay
prejuicio se llama eso y cada tanto
suelen aparecer no
pero bueno no sé si el tiempo los astros
los planetas se alinearon hace más de 20
años para que hoy yo pueda estar acá
contándoles que hace 15 años que tengo
la dicha de acompañar novias madrinas
quinceañeras en una noche que para ella
se soñada que he sido testigo del
nacimiento de nuevas familias que es
celebrado el amor porque tengo la suerte
de trabajar en un oficio del que me
defina morando de a poco en el cual
siempre estoy relacionado con la
celebración de la vida y la felicidad
como siempre digo gracias adiós muertos
por ahora no maquillo
un oficio que después con el tiempo
entendí que me había estado preparando
para ejercerlo desde esos sábados a la
mañana mientras mezclaba colores en el
estudio de eduardo ayala un oficio que
entendí que podía aplicar perfectamente
los mismos conceptos sobre el papel en
un rostro un cuerpo o un cuerpo el día
que entendí eso me enamoré de este
oficio un oficio que me permitió no
solamente recorrer casi todo mi país
descubrir casi todo mi país compartiendo
esto que amo tanto hacer un oficio que
además me permitió conocer lugares del
mundo que jamás en la vida muy bien
imaginado desde esas interminables si
estás entrerrianas en las cuales estaba
como loco me hubieras silva
una cosa fue enamorarme del oficio pero
otra cosa fue entender el poder que
tenía con él
esto sucedió una tarde que se metía en
una novia no estaba pautado pero me
pides y por favor no podía maquillar a
su madre que haya venido es alta
una señora divina pero que me dijo que
nunca se maquillaba hacía mucho que no
son aquella cuestión que la maquilló
terminó de hacerlo y le pido que por
favor se acerca es el espejo que estaba
sobre la chimenea para poder contemplar
lo que había hecho la mujer lo hace se
acerca se mira se da vuelta me mira y
rompe el llanto de una forma tan atroz
que lo primero que se cruzó por la
cabeza fue la que hiciste escarbas
el arriba
vieron que los seres humanos tenemos así
como la condición natural de enseguida
mirar la mitad del vaso vacío o sea
nunca vamos a concentrarnos en la mitad
del vaso ya no esto fue lo que hice yo
dije acá evidentemente algo mal y si
esta mujer lloraba pero ya lado a una
forma como mujer ha visto en celebración
y lloraba para así agachada mirando para
abajo para que las lágrimas caseras
hacia hacia el piso y yo no entendía
cada vez cada vez menos agarró la caja
de pañuelos me acerco le doy uno y esta
mujer decía perdón perdón perdón yo no
entendía nada ya esa altura y en un
momento se levantó un poco y me dice una
frase que ese día cambió mi vida me dice
perdóname por arruinar tu trabajo hacía
mucho tiempo que no me veía así y me
olvidé que podía ser linda
imagínense la situación y yo con mi
metro 90 y parado ella chiquitita
doblada llorando la caja de karina yo no
sabía si darle un caramelo abrazarla dar
un beso alargando a llorar con ella
hasta completar la mitad de ese vaso que
estaba vacío
ese día casi sin querer yo descubrir el
poder del maquillaje el poder de mi
oficio un oficio que mediante la
manipulación y la mentira me permite
lograr que una persona se pueda ver bien
para sentirse mejor
ese día termine de enamorarme
completamente de este oficio
nosotros solemos imaginar
relacionar el maquillaje con lo
superficial con la belleza con lo
efímero con la juventud con la moda o
con la tendencia desde mi punto de vista
que es una herramienta enorme enorme
para ayudar a los demás mediante la
manipulación y la mentira generada a
través de un producto cosmético algo tan
superficial como un producto cosmético
podemos lograr cambios tremendamente
profundos sobre el bienestar de las
personas sea
una modelo una bomba carnavalera o
cualquier persona de cualquier sexo raza
o cultura que pase por las manos de un
maquillador
pero absolutamente nada nada nada se
compara con la satisfacción que me da
saber que cuento mis manos con una
herramienta para lograr que una persona
que sufre de una patología de piel o que
sufre por alguna cuestión determinada un
cambio estético abrupto sobre su persona
pueda a través de lo que yo hago verse
mejor y sentirse mucho mejor
podemos ver acá casos de mujeres con
rosácea un angioma con vitíligo con
cicatrices pacientes oncológicas que a
través del maquillaje logran sentirse
mejor
mi misión como maquillador es lograr la
mejor versión de cada persona
siento que soy un bendecido y hacer lo
que puedo hacer
cuando me invitaron a ser partícipe de
estas charlas mi primera respuesta fue
no porque es de mis propios prejuicios
sentí que como maquillador yo no estaba
habilitado a transmitir una idea que
idea podría transmitir yo sí a mi ciudad
desde lo que yo hago que es algo tan
banal sí y eso me obligó a pensar porque
bajo el eslogan de la ciudad de tus
ideas me hizo reflexionar sobre qué idea
podía transmitir
así que lo pensé lo analice hablé con
las personas indicadas y estoy muy feliz
de poder anunciarles que este mismo
teatro será en el mes de septiembre sede
del primer encuentro nacional de belleza
terapéutica un espacio donde junto a
colegas de la salud y la belleza vamos a
poder debatir analizar y compartir los
beneficios de nuestras profesiones sobre
la autoestima de los demás
en plena época de redes sociales le pedí
a mis seguidores que por favor
despidieran su concepto de belleza en
una sola palabra grande fue mi sorpresa
mucha alegría al comprobar que las
palabras más mencionadas fueron las
siguientes las que estamos viendo ahí
autenticidad autoestima actitud y amor
lo que me lleva a pensar que poco a poco
vamos modificando nuestro pensamiento y
nos enfrentamos a un nuevo paradigma en
el cual belleza sea sinónimo de
pluralidad
cualquiera de ustedes si me pregunta hoy
cuál es tu concepto de belleza yo no
dudaría en decirles la palabra comodidad
es nuestro deber amigamos con nuestro
propio espejo y practicar la empatía
sobre la imagen del otro con tableau de
comodidad le presentó a mi mamá la marga
esa
esa fue la que me enseñó qué belleza
tiene que ver con sentirse bien con uno
mismo con celebrar la vida con animarse
con jugar ya no sentir vergüenza de
dibujarse en la cara un culo de mono
andrés
[Aplausos]